They're introducing
third world practices of
exploitation in the first world.
Vote no on this corporate power grab.
We're not getting benefits.
And I knew that coming into this.
I like the flexibility.
Should Americans be allowed to freelance?
Progressive Democrats have
been pushing legislation
at the state and federal level
that would force companies
like Uber and Lyft in particular
to make all of their
independent contractors
full-time employees.
Would you like to see
this California based law
go nationwide?
Well, of course.
But that movement had a major setback
in the 2020 election
when California voters
came out in favor of severely limiting
the impact of a 2019 law
that, as it was originally written,
would have wiped out the
state's freelance economy.
California voters appear to
have approved Proposition 22.
Assembly Bill Five had
already been weakened
by several carve-outs, but a
referendum on the 2020 ballot
was the biggest blow to
the bill's original intent,
because it means that
Uber and Lyft drivers
will be mostly exempt
from its requirements.
Back in May, Joe Biden called attempts
to gut AB5 unacceptable,
urging Californians to
vote no on the referendum.
Nevertheless, in this
overwhelmingly blue state,
almost 60% approved the
measure at the ballot box.
When Reason covered AB5 earlier this year,
its most vocal opponents turned
out to be freelance writers
on both the left.
This goes too far.
And right.
They're politicians,
they're union workers.
There are people who don't get it.
They're activists.
They're cutting people
off from opportunity.
It didn't occur to California law makers
that many freelancers actually
prefer the flexibility
that comes with being an
independent contractor.
Companies like Vox, which wrote articles
in support of AB5, cut its
staff of independent contractors
because it couldn't afford
to bring them on full time.
Labor activists and progressive lawmakers
were, in effect, deciding
on behalf of workers
that if they couldn't have a
full-time job with benefits,
they would be better off
not having a job at all.
For us, this is about focusing on ensuring
that jobs are good jobs, right?
If we have one or a hundred jobs
that are paying less than minimum wage,
there is absolutely no benefit.
We, I rather have, you know, 50 good jobs
than a hundred bad paying jobs.
And those 50 good jobs are
actually giving a living wage.
Although the law applied
to freelance writers,
its real targets where
gig economy startups
like Uber, Lyft and DoorDash.
Uber and Lyft said that
if AB5 were enforced
as originally written, it would cost
hundreds of thousands
of drivers their jobs,
and may even force the companies
to shut down operations in California.
Basically this is a unions
versus independent workers struggle.
The unions are declining,
except public employees unions,
and so they're desperately
thrashing around
for people that they could organize.
Williamson Evers is a political scientist
and a senior fellow at
the Independent Institute,
a libertarian think tank
in Oakland, California.
He says that Uber and
Lyft weren't bluffing
when they said they'd leave California.
If you say, well, in California,
it's just to be a sinkhole,
nothing but expense
and red tape and crazy labor costs
that are not going to be true
in other places, why go there?
If drivers are forced to become employees,
up to 90% of app based
driving jobs could disappear.
The ride sharing companies
spent more than $200
million on proposition 22,
trying to convince California
voters to exclude them
from AB5, while the law's opponents
spent roughly $20 million.
Proponents of AB five
attribute their defeat
to the fact that they were outspent.
I don't think money
determines political outcomes.
It has an effect on them.
In 2016, Hillary Clinton,
vastly outspent Donald Trump,
and she lost anyway.
It's not really determinative.
The Prop 22 people have
the better argument,
and they took advantage of what they had
to make their case to the people.
I hope that there's some way that
the labor movement can look
at freelancers of all types
and say, this is a valid,
honorable profession,
that we are workers, too.
Many of us choose this field.
We are not exploited.
We're not scabs.
We're small businesses,
and we deserve to be treated that way.
The real exploitation is
the thing that forces people
to work hours that they
don't want to work.
And in ways they don't want to work.